Brian for people who don't know what
Deadpool is in a market sort of
saturated with superhero yeah he's very
unique very fresh isn't it yeah yeah you
realize it's um it's one of those rare
properties that comes along that you
know they're they're reticent to make
and they're they don't want them they
didn't want to make it it was 11 years I
was trying to get them to do a Deadpool
movie but they finally did I think it's
sort of it all works in its favor you
know the anticipation of a Deadpool
movie constantly being asked I mean that
was kind of the worst torture over the
years was people always saying are they
gonna make a Deadpool movie and me
saying I'm trying I'm trying you know
but here we are we get to we get to
introduce them to the world so when they
finally say yes yeah um is your job then
to make sure you do the character
justice cuz you've played them before
obviously brief yes I have yes correct
without any real control yeah before but
this one I bet this film I was lucky
enough I got to produce it and I got to
star in it and I got to really sort of
protect it and I was so vigilant about
the Canon of Deadpool to make sure that
we get every aspect of a write that even
the most kind of scrupulous fan fan boy
or fangirl could sit down and go that's
Deadpool that's the Deadpool I know love
and need how do you make that pitch how
do you go to Fox and bases I want to
take the piss out of your mythology yeah
you wall I mean at Deadpool exists in
the x-men universe in the x-men universe
is a very valuable asset that Fox owns
and it's so it's not easy to do that and
I and truthfully I never got the movie
made I didn't have anything to do with
that it's I begged and pleaded them but
you know we shot a little bit of test
footage of years ago it sat on a shelf
at Fox Dodie did anything with it and
then suddenly one day it accidentally
leaked on the Internet and that was
about a year and a half a coke
accidentally accidentally mix and here
we are I mean that was the fans that
spoke they spoke loud and proud and they
just overwhelmed Fox with with response
over the Deadpool movie so they greenlit
it in within 24 hours and so they
greenlight so they don't give it a sort
of 300 million dollar budget they sort
of they sort of rein back a little bit
on the budget there is that better
feeling that you get mocha mob you know
what it was the best thing that ever
happened to us is that they they made us
make this movie against all odds you
know that they gave us the absolute bare
minimum for a you could never have done
what we did in a Deadpool movie with any
other director I think because Tim
Miller is a visual effects artist so he
really squeezed
ten dollars out of every dollar they
gave us and that was a real help to us
and and not only that we get to rely on
character you know I mean it's Deadpool
is never going to be the guy that's
saving the world because Deadpool sort
of Deadpool doesn't really care about
saving the world
he's like a morally flexible kind of
antihero so so we had a lot of freedom
with what we had and now that felt
really good so where does this character
sit them because he's an anti-hero buddy
lives in this x-men universe yeah you
obviously want to make more of them yeah
is it gonna be standalone cameos is
gonna be standalone movies I mean how
does he fit yeah very well that's the
question there that the studio is asking
and you know it's it's a good question
because for the longest time we weren't
even on the studio's radar now whether
they're sort of prized possession all of
a sudden so I will see what they would
say what they want to do I know that the
way forward is to just continue with
Deadpool standalone films and and dad
will always interact in the x-men
universe he just has to he lives in that
universe but you just have to do it
carefully you just don't want to do too
much or too little
it's got to be standalone surely
otherwise you ruin all the good stuff
you've done in this movie well yeah you
got to do ass analyst that's the whole
point and that's what we want I mean
that's what everybody that's attached to
this and is passionate about as I am
they all want that as well so lovely
happens cool yeah me too nice thank you
Jeff